>>> IN OURORLD LEAD, THE WAR
IN UKRAINIAN IS ENTIRELY THE
FAULT AND RESPONSIBILITY OF ONE
MAN, VLADIMIR PUTIN, THOUGH OF
COURSE, DECADES OF MISJUDGMENTS
IN WESTERN FOREIGN POLICY SET
THE STAGE FOR HIM AS WE HAVE
COVERED BEFORE.
RECENTLY, HOWEVER, FORMER DONALD
TRUMP AND HIS ALLIES HAVE BEEN
ENGAGING IN QUITE A BIT OF
REVISIONIST HISTORY ABOUT THIS
MATTER.
>> IT IS SO SAD.
THIS WOULD HAVE NEVER HAPPENED
IF WE HAD THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
THERE WAS NO CHANCE THIS WOULD
HAPPEN.
AND I KNOW HIM WELL.
AND THIS WAS NOT SOMETHING THAT
WAS GOING TO HAPPEN AT ALL.
>> TRUMP, OF COURSE, FAILING TO
MENTION HIS OWN ACTIONS AND
INACTIONS, AND THAT OF HIS
ADMINISTRATION THAT MAY HAVE
ENABLED PUTIN IN MANY WAYS,
INSTEAD OF CALLING OUT RUSSIA'S
DECADES OF INVASION IN 2008,
ANNEXING CRIMEA IN 2014.
TRUMP IN THIS SAY SEEMS TO FIND
ROOM TO EVEN PRAISE PUTIN AS A
GENIUS FOR THE BRUTAL ATTACK.
EVEN SOME OF TRUMP'S FOREIGN
ADVISERS WONDER IF HIS APPROACH
MAY HAVE EMPOWERED THE RUSSIAN
PRESIDENT ON THE WORLD STAGE.
>> Reporter: AS THE WORLD
WATCHES RUSSIAN TANKS ROLLING
INTO UKRAINE, A CLEARER PICTURE
COMES INTO FOCUS.
NOT ONLY ABOUT VLADIMIR PUTIN'S
WILLINGNESS TO SLAUGHTER
INNOCENTS IN THE NAME OF
RESTORING THE OLD SOVIET EMPIRE,
BUT ALSO --
>> I WOULD LOVE TO GET ALONG
WITH RUSSIA.
>> Reporter: ABOUT HOW OUR
FORMER PRESIDENT CONSISTENTLY
SENT SIGNAL THAT'S HE WAS NOT ON
UKRAINE'S SIDE.
HE WAS ON PUTIN'S.
ON THE VERY DAY TRUMP ANNOUNCED
HIS PRESIDENTIAL RUN IN 2015, HE
MADE THIS CLEAR.
>> I WAS OVER IN MOSCOW TWO
YEARS AGO AND I WILL TELL YOU,
YOU CAN GET ALONG WITH THOSE
PEOPLE AND GET ALONG WITH THEM
WELL.
YOU CAN MAKE DEALS WITH THOSE
PEOPLE.
OBAMA CAN'T.
>> THE WAY HE DENIGRATED ALLIES
AND SPOKE FAVORABLY OF PUTIN,
AND OF OTHER AUTHORITARIANS
AROUND THE WORLD KIND OF GAVE A
CLEAR SIGNAL BOTH TO AMERICAN
ALLIES IN THE WEST AND TO RUSSIA
WHOSE SIDE THIS MAN WOULD BE ON
IF HE WERE IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> Reporter: TRUMP SAID HE WOULD
BE LOOKING TO LIFTING SANCTIONS
AGAINST RUSSIA FOR HAVING
ANEXTED CRIMA AND HE SEEMED TO
BUY PUTIN'S ARGUMENT THAT
RUSSIA'S FIRST UKRAINIAN
ASSAULT, TAKING CRIMEA IN 2014,
WAS NOT SUCH A BIG DEAL.
>> YOU KNOW, THE PEOPLE OF
CRIMEA FROM WHAT I'VE HEARD,
WOULD RATHER BE WITH RUSSIA THAN
WHERE THEY WERE.
>> THAT WAS NOT THE ISSUE.
THE ISSUE WAS THAT IT WAS
ANNEXED ILLEGALLY AGAINST ALL
INTERNATIONAL LAWS.
>> Reporter: PAUL MANAFORT'S,
TRUMP'S SECOND --
>> MANAFORT HAS DONE AN AMAZING
JOB.
>> Reporter: HE WAS THERE FOR
ROUGHLY A DECADE AND WAS PAID IN
PART BY RUSSIAN OLD GARGS,
ACCORDING TO A 2020 SENATE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE REPORT.
DURING MANAFORT'S TIME AS
CAMPAIGN CHAIR, THE CAMPAIGN
PUSHED SOMETIMES BIZARRE AND
SEEMINGLY RANDOM DISINFORMATION
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN WRITTEN BY
THE KREMLIN.
>> YOU HAD THE NATO BASE IN
TURKEY BEING ATTACKED BY
TERRORISTS.
YOU HAD A NUMBER OF THINGS THAT
WEREN'T APPROPRIATE TO THIS
CAMPAIGN, WERE PART OF WHAT MR.
TRUMP HAS BEEN TALKING ABOUT.
>> Reporter: WHEN THE REPUBLICAN
NATIONAL COMMITTEE'S 2016
PLATFORM PROPOSED TO PROVIDE
LETHAL DEFENSIVE WEAPONS TO
UKRAINE IN THE FACE OF THE
RUSSIAN THREAT, THAT LANGUAGE
WAS QUICKLY TABLED AND SOFTENED,
PROMISING ONLY APPROPRIATE
STANCE.
ONCE MANAFORT AND TRUMP'S TEAM
GOT INVOLVED.
>> THAT WAS A BIG VICTORY FOR
THE RUSSIANS AND IT UNDERSCORED
THEIR SENSE THAT THEY WERE GOING
TO REALLY WIN BIG IF TRUMP WON
THE WHITE HOUSE.
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE A MAJOR
ALLY IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> Reporter: TRUMP DENIED ANY
DIRECT INVOLVEMENT WITH THE
CHANGE OF PLATFORM LANGUAGE.
>> I WAS NOT INVOLVED.
IN.
I WAS NOT INVOLVED.
>> Reporter: ONCE IN OFFICE,
TRUMP PUSHED THE NOTION THE U.S.
HAD MORAL EQUIVALENCE WITH
RUSSIA, EVEN AS PERCEIVED
OPPONENTS OF THE KREMLIN KEPT
ENDING UP DEAD OR POISONED.
>> PUTIN IS A KILLER.
>> A LOT OF KILLERS.
YOU THINK OUR COUNTRY IS SO
INNOCENT?
>> Reporter: TRUMP ARGUED RUSSIA
SHOULD BE GIVEN BACK ITS SEAT
EVEN THOUGH IT HAD PUNISHED
UKRAINE.
>> I WOULD RATHER SEE RUSSIA IN
THE G-8 AS OPPOSED THE G-7.
I WOULD SAY THE G-8 IS A MORE
MEANINGFUL GROUP THAN THE G-7.
ABSOLUTELY.
>> YOU HAVE TRUMP LINING UP VERY
CLEARLY WITH RUSSIA.
YOU HAVE HIM AT A MEETING WITH
G-7 LEADERS, TELLING THEM JUST
FORGET ABOUT UKRAINE.
UKRAINE IS RUSSIAN.
LET IT GO.
>> Reporter: AND OF COURSE, THE
DAY AFTER TRUMP FIRED FBI
DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY AMID THE
INVESTIGATION INTO POSSIBLE
COORDINATION BETWEEN RUSSIA AND
THE TRUMP INDICATION THAT, THE
THEN PRESIDENT MET WITH RUSSIAN
PRIME MINISTER SERGE DELAY
LAVROV AND TRUMP REVEALED HIGHLY
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION TO THE
PAIR.
>> WE HAD A VERY, VERY GOOD
MEETING WITH MR. LAVROV, AND IT
WAS, I THOUGHT IT WAS VERY, VERY
GOOD.
>> Reporter: SPECIAL COUNSEL
ROBERT MUELLERER'S REPORT FOUND
MANAFORT AND MICHAEL FLYNN WHO
HAD BEEN PALED BY RUSSIAN
ENTITIES TO ATTEND AND SPEAK AT
THIS 2015 GALA WHERE HE
LITERALLY DINED WITH PUTIN,
TOGETHER PUSHED THE NONSENSICAL
THEORY THAT IT WAS UKRAINE, THAT
RUSSIA, THAT HAD MEDDLED IN THE
2016 ELECTION.
>> DON'T FORGET, UKRAINE HATED
ME.
THEY WERE AFTER ME IN THE
ELECTION.
THEY WANTED HILLARY CLINTON TO
WIN.
>> Reporter: A PRELUDE TO THE
EVENTS THAT PAVED THE WAY TO
TRUMP'S FIRST IMPEACHMENT.
IN SUMMER 2019, TRUMP OUSTED HIS
AMBASSADOR TO UKRAINE AT A
CRITICAL TIME.
FIGHTING HAD CONTINUED IN THE
EAST WITH SEPARATISTS BACK BY
RUSSIA ADDRESS MIGHT'S MIGHT AND
UKRAINE WAS IN DESPERATE NEED
FROM THE U.S.
>> UKRAINE IS IN A WAR WITH
RUSSIA.
AND THE SECURITY ASSISTANCE THAT
WE PROVIDE UKRAINE IS
SIGNIFICANT.
ABSENT THAT SECURITY ASSISTANCE
AND MAYBE EVEN MORE IMPORTANTLY,
THE SIGNAL OF SUPPORT FOR
UKRAINIAN SOVEREIGNTY AND
INTEGRITY THAT WOULD LIKELY
ENCOURAGE RUSSIA TO PURSUE, TO
POTENTIALLY ESCALATE AND PURSUE
FURTHER AGGRESSION.
>> Reporter: WEEKS LATER TRUMP
HAD HIS NOW INFAMOUS QUAL THE
NEWLY ELECTED PRESIDENT
VOLODYMYR ZELENSKYY WHERE HE
ASKED FOR MORE ANTI-TANK J
JAVELINS.
AND TRUMP WANTED UKRAINE IN
EXCHANGE FORM AID TO HELP HIM IN
HIS RE-ELECTION CAMPAIGN BY
ANNOUNCING AN INVESTIGATION INTO
JOE BIDEN, THE DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE TRUMP
FEARED THE MOST, ACCORDING TO
HIS AIDES, AND INTO BIDEN'S SON
HUNTER WHO HAD A LUCRATIVE AND
ETHICALLY DUBIOUS POSITION ON
THE BOARD OF A UKRAINIAN GAS
COMPANY.
>> IT'S JUST YET ANOTHER WAY IN
WHICH TRUMP VERY OPENLY SIDED
WITH PUTIN, AND DISMISSED THE
CONCERNS AND THE NEEDS OF AN
IMPORTANT U.S. ALLY.
>> Reporter: TRUMP WAS BEING
PUSHED BEHIND THE SCENES BY
DEFENSE SECRETARY MARK ESPER
AMONG OTHERS TO GIVE THE
DESPERATELY NEEDED MILITARY AID.
EVENTUALLY ZELENSKYY DID GET THE
WEAPONS HE ASKED FOR AND AN
IN-PERSON MEETING WITH TRUMP,
THOUGH NOT THE ONE HE WANTED IN
THE OVAL OFFICE.
>> WE NEED SUPPORT.
REAL SUPPORT.
AND WE THANK EVERYBODY.
>> Reporter: TRUMP AND HIS
SUPPORTERS TODAY NOTE THAT
UNLIKE DURING THE
ADMINISTRATIONS OF BUSH AND
OBAMA, PUTIN NEVER INVADED ANY
COUNTRY DURING THE TRUMP YEARS,
WHICH IS TRUE.
THOUGH RUSSIA DID SIGNIFICANTLY
RAMP UP ITS MILITARY PRESENCE IN
SYRIA.
BUT FORMER TRUMP NATIONAL
SECURITY VILESOR JOHN BOLT ONLY
SAID THERE COULD BE A REASON
FORM.
>> IN A SECOND TRUMP TERM, I
THINK HE MAY HAVE WELL WITH
DRAWN FROM NATO AND I THINK
PUTIN WAS WAITING FOR THAT.
>> Reporter: THAT SIGNAL HAD
CERTAINLY BEEN SENT.
>> NUMBER ONE.
NATO IS OBJECTION OBSOLETE.
THEY ARE DELIQUENT.
NATO IS OBSOLETE.
>> YOU HAD CANDIDATE TRUMP
TALKING THIS WAY SAYING NATO WAS
OBJECTION LEAST.
HE WANTED TO GET ALONG WITH
RUSSIA.
THAT RUSSIA WAS A SUPER POWER
THAT WE SHOULD TAKE SERIOUSLY
AND RESPECTFUL THAT WAS MUSIC TO
PUTIN'S EARS.
>> Reporter: BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS, THEY HAD ON CONVINCE
TRUMP TO STAND BY NATO.
>> I HAD MY HEART IN MY THROAT
AT THAT NATO MEETING.
I DIDN'T KNOW WHAT THE PRESIDENT
WOULD DO.
HE CALLED ME UP TO HIS SEAT
SECONDS BEFORE HE GAVE THE
SPEECH